Okay.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the line focus channel and my
name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the
Turkish language.
Now,
right off the bat,
the first thing I want to say is that
there is a Turkish language because
Turkey is situated at the edge of the
Middle East.
Some people think that Turkey is an
Arabic country,
but it is not an Arabic country.
The language of Turkey is Turkish,
although there is a small Arabic
speaking minority in Turkey,
there are around 75 million native
speakers of Turkish.
That includes 10 to 15 million people in
southeastern Europe.
That's mainly in the part of Turkey,
that's located in Europe,
but also as a minority language in the
Balkan area,
and it includes 60 to 65 million people
in Anatolia.
That's the part of Turkey that's located
inside of Asia.
Now those numbers are for Turkish,
but there are other languages inside the
Turkic language family that have a
relatively high degree of mutual
intelligibility,
and some people consider those languages
to be dialects of Turkish.
So if we include those,
the number might be as high as 109
million people,
but let's back up and look at the
classification of Turkish.
Because Turkey is located partly inside
of Europe,
you might have thought that Turkish is
an Indo European language or a Slavic
language and because part of Turkey is
located on the edge of the Middle East,
you might have thought that Turkish is a
Semitic language,
but it is none of the above.
The Turkic language family is a separate
family unto itself.
The Turkic languages are sometimes
thought to be a part of larger language
family called the [inaudible] language
family,
which includes some other language
groups like the Mongolian language
family that Japonica and the chorionic
language family amongst others,
but this is not a generally accepted
theory bilinguist it tends to be debated
and these days it seems to be fairly
discredited.
Turkish is part of the ohs branch of the
Turkic language family.
It also includes Azerbaijani,
which is sometimes called Azeri Turkish
as well as Turkmen as well as some other
languages like Qashqai,
which is spoken in some parts of Iran.
The languages of the ohs branch are all
mutually intelligible to some extent,
and these are the languages that are
sometimes considered to be dialects of
Turkish Azeri.
Turkish is spoken in Azerbaijan,
them as well as parts of Iran,
Iraq,
Dagestan,
and Georgia,
and it has 26 million native speakers.
Turkmen has 8 million native speakers,
including 3.5
million in Turkmenistan,
2 million in northwestern Iran and 1.5
million in northwestern Afghanistan.
All Turkic languages descended from a
theoretical language called [inaudible]
Turkish.
Okay.
The Turkic peoples originated in Central
Asia and through migration they expanded
over a wide area extending all the way
from Siberia down through China and
Central Asia through the Middle East,
up into the Balkan area and even north
of the Black Sea owes Turkic the
ancestor language of modern day Turkish
language as well as all the languages of
the ohs branch was brought to Anatolia
by the Seljuk Empire,
a Turkic Empire in the 11th century Ce.
The seljuk empire had previously adopted
Islam and they were admirers of Persian
culture and they were influenced by the
Persian language and the Arabic language
person became the administrative and
literary language.
While Arabic was used for religious
purposes,
but Turkish was still spoken by the
average common people.
Later when the Ottoman empire a rose in
place of the Seljuk Empire,
the official language would be a form of
Turkish that was highly influenced by
Persian and Arabic.
This form of Turkish became known as
ultimate Turkish.
Ottoman Turkish was big stone,
Turkish grammar,
but with some influence from Persian and
Arabic grammar,
but it was the vocabulary that was most
influenced by Persian and Arabic.
Sometimes up to 88% of the vocabulary
used was Persian and Arabic.
This was the language of the elite
people,
not the language of the common people,
which had much less foreign influence,
although it did still have some foreign
influence.
When the modern republic of Turkey was
founded.
In 1923 Mustafa came out,
Ataturk created the Turkish language
association to initiate a reform of the
Turkish language.
He essentially got rid of that
administrative language,
Ottoman Turkish,
and he replaced it with a new standard
language based on the everyday common
language spoken in Istanbul and effort
was made to replace Persian and Arabic
words with native Turkish words.
Sometimes those were archaic Turkish
words that were brought back to life and
sometimes they were newly created
Turkish words taken from Turkish roots
and other big changes that Turkish was
switched from the Arabic alphabet,
the Arabic writing system to a modified
Latin alphabet,
which was much more suitable for reading
and writing.
Turkish Arabic has only three short
vowels and three long vowels while the
Turkish language has eight vowels.
So that created a lot of confusion in
reading and writing in Turkish.
And the literacy rates had always been
very low,
but after switching to the Latin
alphabet,
the literacy rates skyrocketed.
What the common people haven't always
accepted the suggestions by the Turkish
language association.
So some of those foreign loan words in
Turkish still exist alongside and native
Turkish words.
So sometimes there are two words for the
same thing,
one Turkish and one Persian or Arabic,
and they might have the same meaning,
but they're used in a slightly different
way or have a slightly different sense
to the meaning before I mentioned the
Azeri language as well as the Turkmen
language,
which are sometimes considered a
dialects of Turkish,
but they are actually more similar to
the Turkish that was spoken before
auditors reform of the Turkish language.
That is to say that they use more
Persian and Arabic loan words.
Then the modern day standard Turkish of
Turkey uses and also Azerbaijan.
Turkmenistan were under the control of
the USSR for a long time.
So there are also some Russian loan
words and from what I understand,
there are a lot of funny
misunderstandings between the different
varieties of Turkish Azerbaijani or
Azeri.
Turkish was always referred to as
Turkish until the Soviet Union
controlled Azerbaijan and they changed
the name of that language as a way of
trying to create an identity for those
people that was separate from the people
in Turkey.
That was another divide and conquer
tactic.
Just from reading some comments around
the Internet,
the level of intelligibility between
standard Turkish and Azeri Turkish
varies from 60% to 90% but even for the
people who understand less of it,
it seems that they get used to it quite
quickly and it's simply a matter of
familiarity and a little bit of
adjustment.
For example,
one guy wrote in his comment that if a
Turkish person takes an airplane to
Azerbaijan,
maybe in the morning he won't really
understand very well,
but by the afternoon he'll be completely
fluent.
And if that is the case,
then I would definitely say that those
are just two dialects of the same
language.
So let's look at some features of the
Turkish language.
Turkish is an a gluten native language.
A glutenous of means that the words are
comprised of pieces that all add to the
meaning of the word.
So whereas in English,
you might express something with a few
words.
In Turkish,
that might just be one word,
or it might be fewer words,
because instead of using an extra word,
you just add an extra piece to the word
you're already using,
and that means you can sometimes get
some surprisingly long words in Turkish.
Let's look at an example of a gluten
nation thought to be,
yeah,
it's hard to bscs Tattoo bscs Lik Tattoo
bscs licked Larry [inaudible] that in.
Then that'd be a sizzling that in done
mish,
so you can see that if we add a piece to
the end of the word,
we're adding to the meaning of the word.
This way of attaching suffixes to the
end of a word is also used to make
plural forms possessive forums and to
show grammatical case for announce.
Let's look at an example for the plural
form
bash,
lad,
f,
F,
Lad.
Let's look at another example with
possession this time,
Taser,
knees.
Let's look at an example of the
grammatical cases in Turkish.
There are six grammatical cases in
Turkish.
And again,
if you don't know what a grammatical
case is,
that means that the form of the noun
changes depending on its function.
In the sentence,
the word we're using his tree arch,
our June,
uh,
[inaudible],
[inaudible] [inaudible].
So you can see that the form of that now
changes depending on what function it
fulfills in that sentence,
how hard is Turkish to learn?
Well,
that depends on your native language.
If your native language is an a gluten
native language,
or if you know another,
a glutenous of language,
then Turkish might seem more familiar to
you.
But if you have never spoken a language
like that before,
you might have to get used to a whole
new way of thinking.
But the good news is that Turkish
grammar is very systematic and very
consistent.
And so was the writing system.
Turkish is almost entirely a phonetic
language.
That means that for each sound there is
one letter.
So when you read a word,
you know how to pronounce it.
And when you know how to say a word,
you know how to write it.
And as always,
if you're deeply fascinated with the
culture,
then it doesn't matter if the language
is challenging because you will be
motivated enough to get past those
challenges and you'll enjoy it every
step of the web.
So if you happen to be very interested
in Turkey or in Azerbaijan or or other
places where a tricky is just spoken,
then don't hesitate to start learning
the Turkish language.
Thank you for watching the langue focus
channel.
What should the question of the day be?
I can't decide between a couple.
So I'll give you two choices.
So people who speak Turkish or have
studied Turkish,
do you think that Azeri Turkish and
Turkmen or the same language,
dialects of the same language?
How well do you understand each other?
And another question that I'm curious
about Turkish people.
If you tried to read Ottoman Turkish
from that period,
how well do you understand it?
Are there too many loan words,
too much Persian and Arabic for you to
understand more?
Is it close enough that you can
understand it?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Everyone else comment as you wish.
Have a nice day.
Yeah.